after four generations in more than 5.4
million units sold the new say at Ibiza
has been thoroughly revamped but that
doesn't absolutely have to mean improved
let's have a look at what the Spanish
car makers come up with the car tester
Emmanuelle Shaffer knows the CID beats
has always been a practical everyday car
partly because it's so compact the fifth
generations grown a bit larger though
now he'll see if it's got what it takes
to carry on the Ibiza success story at
three point six five metres long and one
point six wide the first he beats in
1984 was noticeably smaller than this
one which adds nearly 40 centimetres of
length and about 20 centimetres of width
but the engines have barely changed in
size the first generation ranging from
0.9 to 1.7 litres in the current one
from one to one-and-a-half the
performance and consumption on the other
hand have been greatly improved more on
that later the new e beats is built on
Volkswagens nqb a zero platform but the
design language is a closed dialect of
the one spoken by big brother Leon
sharply defined contours and tapered
forms predominate
[Music]
unlike previous generations this Ibiza
is available only in a five-door version
sculptured ribs and lines run along the
entire length the rear gives a tight
crisp impression with a hint of the
first generations jutting taillights
position to the outside Emanuel is quite
pleased with the interior the occupants
benefit from the greater width and it
has more space in general so passenger
and Driver don't end up climbing all
over each other
emmanuel likes the accents with colors
matching the exterior paint he also
thinks the way the buttons for the
infotainment system are integrated into
the glass surface look smart and they're
easy to operate the platform allows for
the ibiza to be fitted with technical
features and assistance systems
previously seen only in the upper
vehicle range like the SE at Lyon or the
Atika such as for instance the radar
obstacle scanning prenta cyst with city
emergency braking the adaptive cruise
control and state-of-the-art parking
sensors with a rear-view camera
take off along the immanuel points out
that the he beats his cargo space holds
from 355 to 1165 liters so even with the
rear seat up you've still got room for a
large suitcase and several smaller bags
a line of six inches are available for
the Ibiza the 1 liter TSI and the car we
tested can reach a top speed of 195 km/h
average consumption is factory rated at
four point seven liters per 100
kilometers
yeah the manual thinks the 1 liter TSI
is output of 85 kilowatts is ideal for a
car like this not too much and not too
little
it's zippy and accelerates nicely out of
the curves
it's very nimble while keeping fuel
consumption at a moderate level of all
the first generation he beats a
tormented potential buyers with an
intimidating choice of 14 trim levels
the current generation has cut that down
to a soothingly manageable 5 saving time
and stress no animal sees the new Ibiza
with its larger dimensions an additional
space as a good vehicle for everyday
giving around with 2 or 4 occupants with
the rear seat up or down it's all no
problem of course it won't fit into the
really tight parking spots anymore like
its predecessors did but it's a good car
for getting around town all finished up
the new Ibiza starts at 12,000 490 euros
in Germany a bigger engine and some
options can swiftly push that total up
beyond 25 thousand euros